in many parts of the world scrabble is
viewed as the pastime as a game where
maybe all people play after retirement
and all that but scrabbling Nigerian is
actually very big it is seen as a spot
there is an actual nation scrabble
Federation under the Ministry of sports
they have a lot of young people hoping
to gain an actual living from playing
Scrabble
my name is Wellington G Gary and I'm the
word Scrabble champion I select playing
Scrabble in 1996 when my immediate
Arabella taught me the game it was it
until six years after that I was playing
with some of my neighborhood friends and
they were like ah you are quite good why
not play in tournaments and I was like
wow you mediate ladies in tournaments
and the rest is history ends to say
having an African windy world scrabble
championship is bigger than I can
actually comprehend you needed to have
been in the hole to see the jubilation
of our other African brothers it was
something that everyone in Africa that
play Scrabble has actually looked
forward to Nigeria is a very very
diverse nation we have well over 500
developed languages but the major means
of communication all over Nigeria is
English and since Scrabble is based upon
the English vocabulary is going to be a
way of helping each and every one
improve their command of the English
language relating with the player object
if I hadn't played Scrabble man have
been involved in some other not so
legitimate activities and I think
playing Scrabble it keeps you on the
right track okay we are not blind to the
facts that's the level of unemployment
in the country is very very immense so I
came up with the Wellington foundation
for Scrabble and mine development in
Africa there is a lot of similarities
between how life actually goes and how
Scrabble goes you get to understand that
is not all the time that you get things
your way you really have to
the best out of the little rats you are
given you know each country is known for
a particular sport Brazil for example is
known for football we are hoping to make
scrabble in Nigerian sports about if you
mention Scrabble in any part of the
world ninja should come to mind
you